Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: eric vautier
On nous dit souvent que ce qui ne
nous tue pas nous rend plus fort.
C’est une phrase qu’on aime
nous répéter pour s’encourager
à se remettre des épreuves de la vie.
Eh bien, moi, je viens
aujourd’hui vous dire que
je vis avec les conséquences
de ce qui ne m’a pas tuée.
Ça ne m’a pas rendue plus forte
mais ce qui est sûr,
c’est que ça m’a transformée.
Je vais aujourd’hui vous parler d’un sujet
qui me tient très à cœur,
qui est le trouble
dissociatif de l’identité.
C’est un trouble mental, en abrégé le TDI,
qui touche 1 à 3 %
de la population mondiale.
Et tout démarre dans l'enfance.
C’est bien souvent là
que tout prend racine
et va déterminer la personne
que l’on va devenir.
Il y a des enfants qui vont
avoir une enfance heureuse,
une vie saine, équilibrée.
Leur identité va pouvoir bien
se développer et se former.
Et pour d’autres,
il va y avoir une cassure
comme un bol que se brise.
Le bol c’était moi,
et ce qui m’a brisée,
c’était des traumatismes que je vivais.
Ça peut être de l’abus,
de la négligence,
des violences physiques, verbales,
émotionnelles, sexuelles…
Pour une enfant, ça fait beaucoup.
Au final, mon cerveau, ce qu’il a décidé,
c’est qu’il fallait garder séparés
tous les états de conscience
qui forment une personne.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
le processus d’intégration.
Quand on est petit, les états de
conscience qui forment un enfant
s’unifient pour développer et devenir
la personne que l’on va devenir.
Eh bien, mon cerveau,
il a décidé de ne jamais intégrer.
Il a décidé de faire ça pour survivre
aux traumatismes qu’on vivait,
parce qu’il s’est dit :
« Elle toute seule, avec ce qu’elle vit,
ça ne va pas passer.
Elle va avoir besoin d’autres personnes,
d’autres personnalités comme on dit dans
le langage courant » - j’y reviendrai.
Et c’est ainsi que j’ai grandi.
Arrive le collège,
des nouvelles cassures…
Arrive le lycée,
encore des nouvelles cassures...
Au final,
j’arrive à ma première année post bac.
C’était comme
si j’étais rescapée d’un tsunami
dont toutes les épreuves m’avaient
fait perdre des petits bouts de moi.
Et j’étais anéantie.
Je ne savais plus quoi faire.
C’était très compliqué.
Au final, le bol avait fini en miettes.
Et comment on fait
pour recoller des miettes ?
Eh bien, j’ai essayé
de recoller les miettes
pour former des morceaux
pour ensuite reconstituer le bol.
Et je peux vous dire
que ce n’était pas simple.
Je suis passé par l’automutilation -
c’est devenu une addiction,
par les troubles alimentaires aussi –
contrôler la moindre calorie
me donnait l’impression
que je contrôlais ma vie entière
alors qu’en fait,
je ne contrôlais plus rien du tout.
C’était compliqué.
J’avais l’impression d’être folle,
d’être complètement folle,
de ne pas réussir à faire ce que
la plupart des personnes faisaient
parce que je ne vivais plus.
En vérité, je survivais.
Il pouvait m’arriver parfois
de partir en bus le matin, très tôt…
Et puis d’un coup je me retrouvais
en plein milieu d’aprèm
dans une rue que je ne connaissais pas,
sans savoir où j’étais,
pourquoi j’étais là,
si on m’avait fait du mal ou pas…
Et ça, ça résulte
dans des symptômes du TDI,
qui est l’amnésie.
L’amnésie, elle peut être partielle
mais elle peut aussi être totale.
Et c’est quand elle est totale
que ça fait très peur
parce qu’on ne contrôle plus
vraiment sa vie.
On m’a aussi dit que mon comportement
changeait très souvent
de façon assez drastique.
Je me rappelle une fois en 5e où
j’ai reçu une très mauvaise note.
J’ai reçu un zéro alors que j’étais
une très bonne élève en français.
Ma prof, plutôt que de m’engueuler,
au contraire, elle s’est inquiétée :
« Christina, est-ce que ça va ? »
Ben je n’ai pas su quoi répondre.
J’avais l’impression, pendant le contrôle
qu’on avait enlevé mon cerveau pour mettre
celui de quelqu’un d’autre à la place.
Je voyais ce qui se passait,
je voyais mon contrôle,
et je ne contrôlais plus rien…
C’est comme si, au lieu d’être pilote
de mon propre corps,
j’étais devenue le passager seulement.
Donc les infos dont j’avais besoin
pour mon contrôle,
que je savais en moi,
impossible d’y avoir accès,
donc j’ai eu zéro.
Au final, le verdict est tombé.
J’avais le TDI.
Et autre nouvelle, en fait,
on ne guérit pas du TDI.
Il n’y a pas de médicament magique
qui va recoller les morceaux du bol.
Donc à ce moment-là,
qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Au final, j’ai décidé de me renseigner
sur les états de conscience.
Je vous en parlais tout à l’heure.
Les états de conscience, on les appelle
dans le TDI, des « alters ».
Des « alters », des personnalités
dans le langage courant, mais,
quand on parle dans le domaine médical,
on parle d’alters.
Ce sont simplement des états de conscience
qui sont plus ou moins dissociés
qui indépendamment des uns et des autres
vont pouvoir contrôler le corps
selon la situation
et simplement pour survivre.
Et l’ensemble des alters dans un corps,
c’est ce qu’on appelle un système.
Moi, j’ai un système
d’une quinzaine d’acteurs environ.
Chacun a son rôle,
mais la question qu’on me pose -
je pense - le plus souvent, c’est :
« Comment ça se passe
intérieurement pour toi
quand il va y avoir
un changement au contrôle ?
Qu’est-ce qui se passe
de ton point de vue interne à toi,
quand un autre alter va prendre
le contrôle de ton corps ? »
Eh bien, pour ça il faut imaginer
que le corps, c’est une voiture.
C’est l’image la plus simple – je pense –
pour se le représenter.
Par exemple je suis devant vous,
c’est moi, Christina.
Je peux vous parler, vous entendre,
on peut communiquer.
Je sais ce qu’il se passe autour de moi.
Eh bien, ça veut dire que
je suis pilote de la voiture.
C’est moi qui suis au contrôle.
Mais il se peut aussi que,
pour une raison ou une autre,
eh bien, je voie ce qui se passe,
je vous entende
mais que je ne contrôle plus mon corps.
Dans ce cas-là, c’est que
je suis passagère juste à côté du pilote.
Je vois ce qui se passe
mais je ne peux rien contrôler.
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé en 5ème
quand j’ai eu ma mauvaise note.
J’étais devant ma copie,
et d’un coup, je n’étais plus pilote.
J’étais le passager
pour une raison ou une autre.
Il se peut aussi que les choses deviennent
encore plus floues pour moi.
Je comprends à peu près ce qui se passe,
je vois à peu près ce qui se passe, mais
je contrôle de moins en moins.
J’ai moins la notion du temps.
Dans ces cas-là,
je suis sur la banquette arrière.
Pendant ce temps-là, c’est d’autres alters
qui vont être pilote et passagers.
La dernière situation,
je pense que c’est la plus effrayante,
c’est quand je ne contrôle
plus rien du tout,
que je ne sais pas la durée
entre le moment où j’étais pilote et le
moment où j’ai changé de position.
Là c’est quand on est
dans le coffre de la voiture.
C’est assez effrayant
car on ne sait pas le temps
qu’on va rester dans le coffre,
ni ce qui va se passer dans la voiture,
si on va avoir un accident ou pas,
si les personnes qui sont
pilote et passagers
vont réussir à nous garder en sécurité.
C’est au final
la partie la plus effrayante.
Les alters sont créés par le cerveau
pour survivre
parce que, à un moment donné,
les traumatismes étaient tels
que je ne pouvais plus
vraiment vivre toute seule.
J’avais besoin d’aide.
Donc chaque alter a son propre rôle.
Il peut y avoir des alters protecteurs,
des alters qui vont gérer
la vie sociale, le travail,
plein d’autres choses encore…
Dans notre système, on a d’ailleurs
ces différents rôles-là.
J’ai par exemple une alter qui est
un petit peu la maman de notre système.
C’est comme ça que
je me la suis toujours figurée.
Elle s’appelle Violette.
Elle est plus âgée que moi.
Elle a toujours été plus âgée
que moi, d’ailleurs,
et elle représente l’alter
dont j’ai les souvenirs les plus anciens.
Je me souviens d’elle
quand j’étais toute petite
et je pense que si elle était là
et qu’elle a été créée
en tant que maman du système,
c’est parce qu’à l’époque
où j’étais une enfant,
et que je vivais
les traumatismes que je subissais,
j’avais besoin d’une maman.
Donc à défaut d’en avoir une sur place,
mon cerveau a décidé de la créer.
On pouvait s’auto-suffire en quelque sorte
et je pouvais l’entendre parler.
C’est comme ça qu’on communique –
c’est dans la tête.
Ce ne sont pas des hallucinations
puisque ce sont vraiment
des états de conscience en moi.
Je n’ai pas conscience
que c’est moi qui me parle à moi-même.
On est tellement dissociés que,
pour moi, c’est d’autres personnes.
Et je pouvais l’entendre me dire :
« Ne t’inquiète pas, ça va aller.
Tout va bien, je suis là pour toi. »
Et je pense que c’est dont j’avais besoin
pour survivre, justement.
Au final, on peut se demander :
« C’est bien beau d’avoir
tous ces alters dans sa tête,
mais qu’est-ce qui se passe après ça ?
Eh bien, après ça, on a deux choix.
On a le choix d’aller en thérapie
et c’est ce que j’ai fait.
J’ai décidé d’avoir
un suivi psychiatrique,
puis un suivi psychologique.
Dans ce cas-là,
en thérapie, on a deux choix.
Le premier, c’est la fusion des alters.
On peut décider
de faire fusionner des alters entre eux.
Les morceaux du bol vont se recoller
et ça va donner une nouvelle identité.
Et petit à petit, on peut réussir à faire
fusionner tous les alters entre eux
jusqu’à devenir plus
qu’une seule identité.
Un peu comme quand on prend
du rouge et du bleu, ça donne du violet.
Eh bien, c’est ça.
Ça donne un nouvel alter.
Mais c’est quelque chose qui est
assez fastidieux et compliqué
parce que ça demande
beaucoup de travail en thérapie.
C’est très, très long.
Il faut guérir de ses traumatismes.
On n’a pas la garantie
qu’il n’y ait pas un nouveau traumatisme
qui va de nouveau créer une cassure
et de nouveau créer de nouveaux morceaux.
Moi au final,
je ne connais qu’une personne
qui a réussi à faire fusionner
tous ses alters
pour ne devenir qu’une seule identité
et c’est une femme
d’une trentaine d’années environ.
Elle est maman maintenant
et ça fait dix ans, même plus de dix ans,
qu’elle est en thérapie
et elle a réussi à faire ça.
Il y a une deuxième solution,
c’est le fait de réaliser qu’en fait,
même en étant un bol cassé,
on n’est pas destiné
à finir à la poubelle.
On peut réussir à vivre en multiplicité.
Et d’ailleurs, moi, je ne vois pas
comment on peut réussir à vivre
en étant tout seul parce que
j’ai toujours grandi avec des alters.
J’ai toujours été aidée
et c’est comme si on pouvait dire que
je ne suis pas vraiment conçue
pour survivre par moi-même.
J’ai besoin de mes alters.
Ils ont besoin de moi aussi.
Donc au final,
on arrive à vivre en harmonie.
Bien sûr, ça demande aussi
beaucoup de travail
parce que, l’amnésie, ce n’est pas
quelque chose qu’on a envie d’avoir,
surtout quand on se retrouve
dans le coffre.
C’est dangereux.
Donc avec la thérapie, avec le fait
de travailler sur ses traumatismes,
on peut réussir à réduire au maximum
les barrières amnésiques
qu’il y a entre les alters
et qui font que, des fois,
sans avoir le contrôle de la situation,
on peut se retrouver dans le coffre.
Moi, ça fait longtemps que, maintenant
je ne me retrouve plus dans le coffre,
mais ça ne garantit pas que
ça ne m’arrivera plus non plus.
Ça peut arriver s’il y a des déclencheurs.
Il peut y avoir des déclencheurs positifs
et des déclencheurs négatifs.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
des « triggers » en anglais.
Un trigger positif, ça peut être
une musique, par exemple,
ou un événement joyeux
qui va potentiellement
faire venir un autre alter.
Et un trigger négatif, bien souvent,
c’est simplement quand on va
se rappeler un traumatisme,
quelque chose qui nous rappelle
ce qu’on a vécu.
Ça peut être des insultes.
Ça peut être quelqu’un qui nous
touche sans qu’on ait consenti.
Ça peut être compliqué mais,
avec la thérapie, on peut s’en sortir.
Au final, moi,
ça me faisait du bien de savoir
que je n’étais pas folle.
Le verdict était tombé, j’avais le TDI.
Donc j’ai réalisé que
je pouvais vivre comme ça.
Je pouvais vivre ainsi en multiplicité.
J’ai décidé de me renseigner sur Internet,
sur ce qui était le TDI.
Je pense que c’est le réflexe premier
qu’on a quand on a une maladie,
de chercher sur Doctissimo,
ce genre de sites.
Moi, ce que j’ai vu,
c’était des choses très alarmantes
par rapport au TDI.
Le TDI, c’est un trouble
qui est très négatif.
C’est un trouble qui est controversé.
C’est un trouble même
de personnes dangereuses.
Les gens qui ont le TDI sont dangereux.
Un peu peut-être comme vous le savez
avec le mythe de Docteur Jekyll
et Mister Hyde ;
même le film « Split », je pense que
certains d’entre vous l’ont vu.
Tous ces sites-là
voulaient me faire croire
que j’avais forcément un monstre en moi.
que c’était moi qui allais
attaquer des gens,
qui allais faire du mal aux gens.
Eh bien, tout ça c’est faux ;
tout simplement parce que
dans 99% des cas,
les personnes qui ont le TDI,
ce ne sont pas des agresseurs,
ce sont des victimes.
Elles le sont de leur enfance,
parfois jusqu’à la fin de leurs jours.
On sera toujours des victimes,
très rarement des agresseurs.
Et le trouble, il est officiel.
Il est reconnu.
Il est étudié en fac, notamment.
Donc pour moi,
toutes ces théories alarmistes,
ce sont simplement des préjugés qui
nous empêchent un petit peu plus
d’avoir un diagnostic
et d’avoir de l’aide.
Au final,
je vous disais tout à l’heure que
ce qui ne m’avait pas tuée
ne m’avait pas rendue plus forte.
Eh bien c’est vrai.
Ça ne m’a pas rendue plus forte.
Ça m’a affaiblie.
J’ai vécu avec les conséquences
de mes traumatismes toute ma vie.
Ça fait 15 ans environ et pourtant
je ne suis pas passée à côté.
J’ai toujours des automatismes
de personnes traumatisées.
J’ai des phobies, des angoisses.
Je peux avoir des flashbacks
aussi dans la journée.
Je peux toujours avoir des problèmes
avec l’automutilation, notamment.
J’ai développé une énorme phobie
de l’abandon qui m’handicape au quotidien.
Ce qui ne m’a pas tuée
ne m’a pas rendue plus forte.
Ça, c’est sûr.
Mais je ne pense pas qu’on puisse dire
que des traumatismes peuvent
vraiment rendre plus fort.
Pour moi, un traumatisme
n’a jamais lieu d’être.
Un enfant ne méritera jamais
d’avoir des traumatismes.
Et on ne pourra jamais
le justifier en disant :
« Mais ce n’est pas grave que
tu aies vécu des traumatismes,
ça t’a rendu plus forte,
ça t’a appris des choses. »
Ce n’est pas vrai.
J’ai dû construire ma vie autour de ça.
J’ai dû arrêter la fac
à cause de ma santé mentale.
J’ai perdu beaucoup de relations.
Comme je vous le dis, des fois,
je peux toujours faire des crises
d’angoisse ou de panique.
C’est compliqué à vivre au quotidien.
C’est très compliqué.
Peut-être même qu’il y a
des gens dans cette salle
qui ont vécu des traumatismes infantiles.
Peut-être que vous en connaissez
ou même qu’il y a des personnes
qui ont vécu le TDI aussi parmi vous
et qui ont ce trouble-là.
Ce qui ne nous tue pas ne nous
rend pas nécessairement plus fort.
Mais je suis persuadée
qu’avec beaucoup de temps,
de patience,
de travail aussi sur ses traumatismes et
d’avoir le courage de demander de l’aide,
je pense que le bol, même
après avoir été brisé mille fois,
il peut quand même être réparé.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)